[Music]
hey what's up Wolfgang just a quick news
video here because yesterday the Russo
brothers came out and they told us the
fate of some characters who were not on
screen at the end of Avengers infinity
war I'm sorry if you have not seen
Avengers infinity war this is your
spoiler alert and you should click away
from this video right now so first off
Howard the Duck he's alive
the recent mother's came out and they
said that Howard the Duck survived
Thanos a snap this leaves it open for
him to return in guardians of the galaxy
vol 3 or possibly his own solo movie
next is Lady SIF she's gone she did not
survive
thanassis nap next is Sheree when the
rooster brothers were asked about where
Sheree was they deemed her whereabouts
as a potential spoiler however I really
don't think that they would kill off
Sheree and besides it has been heavily
rumored that she will be in Avengers for
Matt Damon's character who acted as loki
in the beginning of thor ragnarok he's
dead in fantastic news it seems like
Korg and meek are alive their
whereabouts were deemed as potential
spoilers by the Russo brothers but Kevin
Feige announced that there are
definitely plans for Corden and meek in
the MCU so that leads me to believe that
they are alive Black Panthers Nakia
status is currently unknown but when the
Russo brothers were asked why she wasn't
in infinity war they admitted that she
was on missions and that she is deep
undercover right now so she's most
likely alive and last but not least Aunt
May she's alive and she probably won't
be too happy to find out from Tony Stark
that her nephew is dead so these are the
off-screen characters that the Russo
brother talked about in an interview
last night are you excited for the
characters that are still alive and
bummed out about the ones that are dead
I know I'm excited because I'm ready for
Corrigan week to come back and start a
revolution let me know in the comment
section below and be sure to give this
video a like if you enjoyed it also
subscribe to my channel if you want to
stay up-to-date on Avengers infinity war
Avengers for all things marvel and
superhero thank you so much for watching
woof woof
hey hey he picked easy man allow me to
introduce myself my name is